امرت هيئه المحلفين في نيويورك الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بدفع غرامه
قدرها خمسه ملايين دولار للكاتبه
الامريكيه كارول التي اتهمته في وقت سابق
بضربها واغتصابها في متجر للملابس
والتشهيبها فبعد اسبوعين من جلسات
الاستماع للشهود خرجت كارول من المحكمه
مبتسمه بعد ان اعلنت هيئه المحلفين عن
براءه ترامب من قضيه الاغتصاب التي اتهمته
بها كارول كون الهيئه لم تجد اي دليل
لواقعه الاغتصاب لكنها امرت ترامب بدفعه
لغرامه قدرها خمسه ملايين دولار للاعتداء
عليها بالضرب والتحرش بها والتشهير وصفه
لها بانها كاذبه طبعا ترامب لم يلتزم
الصمت وكعادته كتب على منصه وقال انه لا
يعرف من هي هذه المراه وان هذا الحكم
ازعاج بالنسبه له عاد ترامبو نشر منشورا
اخر قال فيه ان الحكمه غير عادل ولابد
مشاهدينا ان نذكر ان ترامب قال سابقا بان
هيئه المحلفين لم تسمح له بالدفاع عن نفسه
بالاتهامات الكاذبه لكارول على الرغم من
انه مرشح سياسي حالي وقال انه مهما كانت
النتيجه سيستانف الاسكاتا غير الدستوري له
كمرشح
[موسيقى]